I'm really curious like is it true
I I told you I I was wondering that it
seems like I'm seeing like Society make
a bigger deal about jokes than actual
crime is that accurate do you see that
[Music]
hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast I have the pleasure of sitting
this morning with Matt orphalia Matt
have I pronounced your name correctly
that's not it but that is why I go by
ORF because it is almost impossible to
pronounce correctly in fact if you had
pronounced my name correctly which is
orphala and anybody had typed that in
they wouldn't be able to find me so it's
actually better to mispronounce it
because that way people will be able to
find me okay so you go by Matt ORF but
it's orfila yeah yeah is that right it's
crazy yeah it is I know it doesn't seem
right but that's that's what I'm told am
I am I I'm dredging up out of a deep
Dusty quadrant of memory here actually
full of cobwebs isn't orfula a genus of
spider
um I don't know I don't know I don't
know all right I don't know all I mean I
don't come from a family of spiders as
far as I know but well you know do you
know what Weinstein means no Weinstein
is the uh glass-like sediment in the
process of red wine making it's wine
Stone and I don't come from a family of
wine sediment so you know last names are
not always a perfect indicator of uh of
one's history but in any case I should
say you are a video creator uh fast on
the rise that makes I uh I will in the
moment let you describe what these
things are but these are video
uh compilations curations that are
simultaneously jaw-dropping in their
implication and hilarious in the
juxtaposition of uh things that are
relevant to uh important current events
uh so anyway I don't know if that's how
you describe it you want to yeah
that sounds good to me that's a huge
compliment especially coming from you
and I mean the way I describe it is I
just try to make videos that kind of
fight back against groupthink
and one of the Styles that's I've done
that's you know probably the most
popular is mashups or remixes and so
I'll Mash Up remix the news in a way to
kind of reveal
the propaganda
interesting so uh as you probably know I
was a college professor for uh 14 years
and
my key trick for teaching was to say
things that would cause these were true
things but they would cause the mind to
register an error you know things that
were juxtaposed in such a way that they
didn't make immediate sense which forces
the mind to become conscious and it
sounds to me like what you're doing is
mashing up the news in a way that the
Mind cannot help but see what is in
front of it whereas I think
largely it has taken in subliminally as
it is presented by those who make it
yeah yeah and also it's it's hard to
comprehend how
uh you know just
overbearing and ominous the propaganda
is
um so but if you condense it all which I
try to do
um then it's like you know undeniable
you know it's very clear to see the
narrative uh but you know it's it's hard
to make make it out if you know it's
split up between all these commercial
breaks and you know yeah it's uh it's
actually it's partially designed and
partially it has evolved to become
invisible
um which is extremely dangerous
and I I would say I would just add
Heather and I used to do a lot of
traveling to remote places as uh you
know as part of our graduate work in
biology and one of the things that was
most shocking about it was what happened
when you came home
where you could briefly you know for a
week or two after you'd been away for
three six
10 18 months sometimes
you could come home and you could
actually see your culture as it is
rather than see it as a participant and
the
um presentation of events and
advertisements
are just hard to believe when you see
them with your conscious mind right they
only work because you're only half
paying attention
yeah
so uh anyway yeah your videos
um really do an excellent job at this
I forgot to mention your DC based is
that right yeah
but as a video editor I suppose you know
I could be working anywhere but anyway
you could be on Mars yeah yeah
so I first became aware of your work
when you tell me if I have the story
correct here you put together a video I
know no longer even remember the exact
detail of the content but I was somehow
involved in this video I was part of the
mashup
and you got flagged by YouTube you got
struck
if I recall correctly but the very
strange thing about that story
again tell me if I'm wrong but you had
not made the video public
that's right there were
um
at three uh rough cuts that I had
uploaded
just uploaded to YouTube
and they were removed
before I even published them and I
wasn't planning on publishing those they
were old rough Cuts some you know which
makes sense helps my process to upload
it on YouTube unlisted or private and
then just kind of view it see how it
plays in the little YouTube screen with
the YouTube compression and all anyway
yeah the YouTube deleted it gave me that
was my first uh strike
um then all of a sudden they started
deleting older videos of mine uh
claiming that that I was somehow
supporting violent criminal
organizations am I am I the violent
criminal organizer you were supporting
Maybe YouTube thinks so but uh well
they've certainly they certainly behaved
that way but you know the story was just
so shocking because you know I suppose I
could imagine
YouTube has some mechanism for looking
at content that is not public and I
could imagine you getting an email
saying you can't make this one public
for some reason Matt but what I can't
imagine is that you would get a
community guidelines strike for
something we had not published I mean
yeah it makes a mockery of the term
Community what
exactly did you do that violated a
community standard here you know all you
did was upload something to see
technically how it would work yeah I
mean this video was basically
um a mashup of it was funny funny enough
it was about the censorship of the
Ivermectin discussion
um I even had a disclaimer even in my
rough Cuts but it didn't matter and you
know I featured you and you know you
just discussing basically the main point
it ends with your you know big point
which was if Ivermectin you know could
help covet
um
you know this was this is just
incredibly dangerous and disastrous and
like frankly you know evil to be
censoring a potential
um cure that you know that the science
had not been settled on yet right
um
so yeah I mean just so make the video
about censorship got censored and when
you're deleting material that was never
uh made public I mean that's essentially
uh that's thought crime stuff right
there yep it's thought crime pre-crime
whatever it might be but I will also say
you know it's funny we're now
um what a couple years down the road
from that incident
and
the story of kovid has evolved quite a
bit
it's interesting that Ivermectin is
the slowest of the various topics to
actually
arrive at some place where we can have
an open discussion about it many people
still believe the propaganda that says
look it was promising we studied it it
doesn't work and certain people won't
get over the fact that it doesn't work
right that is not at all the case if you
look at the evidence with a critical eye
but somehow that story has maintained
even as the story that the vaccines are
safe and effective that they don't
produce the evolution of viral variants
that the uh pathogen was altered in a
laboratory before it emerged into the
world all of these things are now
readily discussable but Ivermectin
remains Radioactive
as do I because of my willingness to
talk about what the evidence said
to correct where I had the evidence
wrong and to say look I I don't you know
doesn't matter how stigmatized the
position is the evidence still indicates
that this is a powerful and safe drug to
use that is effective against
uh covid but
I guess I wonder what you make of the
fact that that particular story has
remained that of all the stories that
have broken that one has remained most
intact
I guess well yeah I haven't seen
evidence that um
Ivermectin works against covid yet
um but
I'm all for an open discussion about
that sure and I would say I have seen
that evidence this episode is sponsored
by Sundays a fantastic and unique dry
dog food made with your dog's health in
mind our dog Maddie also known as the
blonde lightning thinks that Sundays is
out of this world when Sundays
approached us about being a sponsor we
were dubious she is after all a Labrador
and Labs will eat basically anything
what possible difference was she going
to show in interest between her usual
kibble a widely available high-end brand
and Sundays
but we were wrong Maddie loves the food
Sundays makes she seriously loves it and
it is far better for her than the
standard burnt kibble that comprises
most dried dog food Sundays is the first
and only human grade air dried dog food
combining the nutrition and taste of all
natural human grade foods with the ease
of a zero prep ready to eat formula
Sundays is an amazing way to feed your
dog and in a pinch a person too probably
Sundays is easy for humans no fridge no
prep no cleanup no gross wet dog food
smells Sundays is gently air dried and
ready to eat no artificial binders
synthetic additives or general garbage
seriously look at the label
all of Sunday's ingredients are easy to
pronounce except quinoa which is spelled
quinoa for some reason in a blind taste
test Sunday's outperformed leading
competitors 40 to zero that sounds like
a made-up number I know but here's the
thing when I have a bowl of Maddie's
previous food ready for her she is
certainly enthusiastic again she is a
lab but when I have a bowl of Sundaes
ready for her it's a whole different
level of enthusiasm she bounces and
Spins and leaps in anticipation
do you want to make your dog happy with
her diet and keep her healthy try
Sundays we've got a special deal for our
listeners receive 35 percent off your
first order go to Sundays for dogs.com
Darkhorse or use dark horse at checkout
that's
s-u-n-d-a-y-s-f-o-r-d-o-g-s.com forward
slash Darkhorse switch to Sundays and
feel good about what you are feeding
your dog
I think the thing that people do not
anticipate is the degree of propaganda
that one encounters when you get
anywhere near this drug right
um and so I agree yes there are several
studies that appear to settle the
question once and for all it's not
effective but they settle it in the
abstract that is to say in the first
paragraph where they describe what
they've found
the evidence that is actually in the
papers
does not reflect the conclusion that is
reported what is there in the method
section is sabotage
these studies were designed to fail and
the irony is the drug is effective
enough that in spite of Designing the
studies to fail they didn't fail
completely so the evidence that they
produced actually does reflect an
effectiveness of ivermectin even though
they administered it late which
everybody knows doesn't work when you
are talking about an antiviral treatment
they cryptically hid a dosage cap right
the people who are most threatened by
covet are people who are very overweight
and they hid the the dosage of
ivermectin is supposed to be per
kilogram
and what they did is they hid a
mechanism that capped the dosage so the
fattest people got the lowest dose per
kilogram right there's no no scientific
explanation for why you would do that
none has ever been offered but
nonetheless they buried it in this you
see it in two different studies the ones
that are trumpeted is settling the
question so I think most people do not
imagine that if you dig in a scientific
study done you know by supposedly
reputable institutions in the west that
you're going to find outright fraud and
yet that's what is here which tells you
something about the importance of this
question
I mean I should also just add as long as
we're on the topic
people also have this wrong idea
you know Ivermectin is very useful at
treating parasitic infections and they
thought that it might be useful for
treating covid and then it turned out
that it didn't
that's not the story the story is
Ivermectin is actually extremely
effective against a range of RNA viruses
of which covid is one so if it didn't
work for covid that would be the
exception the fact that it does work for
covid means it's just consistent across
RNA viruses it works against them and
covet is not exceptional is it a fact at
this point what that it works for
against covet depends what you mean by
fact I thought you I yeah well let's put
it this way from my perspective it is uh
as close to a fact as you're going to
get that even the studies that claim it
doesn't work if you look at the evidence
those studies produced rather than the
way they summed up that evidence yes it
is effective and you wouldn't expect it
to be very effective in these studies
because it was given so late
all antivirals have a non-linear
relationship with time given the earlier
you give them the better they work the
the efficacy and the effectiveness drops
off the later you administer them and so
um
the you know the studies were designed
not to show an effect and did anyway
that's how good the drug is
hmm yeah I mean
this I'm not a biologist and I mean I'm
just against censorship and I
more studies sounds good anybody that
wants to censor the the science and the
discussion that's horrible
um
I guess I think one of the what about
like hydroxychloroquine did that ever I
remember there was a lot of questions
about that you know hope uh but it
didn't follow through in some studies
some studies apparently did suggest that
it was effective whatever happened with
that one same pattern the fact is and
there's a reason for this or there
appears to be a reason for this the
reason appears to be that the emergency
use authorization for the so-called
vaccines required that there be no
viable Treatment available the idea that
there Not only was a viable Treatment
available but there were several of them
they were highly effective and They
Carried virtually no risk meant there
was no reason to expose the human
population to this radical experiment of
especially
mrna-based vaccines for which there was
no precedent in humans for a successful
use
yeah so yeah so now I will say among my
errors in covid was I missed for too
long that hydroxychloroquine was
actually an effective drug I bought the
propaganda and only late in covid did I
discover actually that was wrong that
they had sold us again just like they
did with Ivermectin two wrong ideas one
it doesn't work there's no evidence for
efficacy two it's dangerous you'd be a
fool to take it right the way they got
the evidence of danger was they hugely
overdosed people right they actually did
harm in studies in order to to make a
safe drug look dangerous that's that's
how crazy this propaganda is
yeah I
I yeah I mean I wish I could have better
you know more to say on this topic you
should not you shouldn't you know you're
a lay person
the problem is you are stuck in an
impossible bind
right are you supposed to imagine that
scientific evidence isn't scientific
evidence when it comes to certain drugs
that do or don't work against certain
diseases you're not in a position to
know right you don't know that I'm not
crazy so I wouldn't I wouldn't expect
you to have a sophisticated position
here but I would point out that the idea
that hey I'm for more studies
sure doesn't address the question if the
the thing that has captured our
journalistic apparatus our regulatory
apparatus if that thing has captured our
scientific apparatus so that it cannot
do a study without
influences that cause foregone
conclusions to be manifest in studies to
supposedly settle questions but in the
direction that is not true then more
studies doesn't help
because the fact is science works on the
honor System
it really you know you have to report
what you did honestly and you have to
set up your experiment to function and
even peer review doesn't tend to catch
major errors for example the the
underdosing of overweight coveted
patients right apparently peer review
didn't catch that these papers emerged
that
unexplained sabotage remained in there
and nobody said anything
yeah the whole
um
yeah I mean just because there's a
scientific scientific study doesn't mean
it was done right and unfortunately
that's uh that complicates things very
much
um and we you know this was people some
people already knew this uh like
yourself
um because you know you you worked in
science but um
you know now it's more undeniable and
even some of the studies from uh on the
vaccines I remember Thomas Massey he
noticed an error in like a CDC
um report
or study and contacted them over the
phone recorded it all
they eventually admitted it wasn't
accurate
and they never really fully uh corrected
it I mean it's just a
amazing
um Just one thought though I had on so
in during covid uh
when I was discussing like potential you
know these these taboo
possible remedies right
a lot of the times I would be
given anecdotes so people saying that oh
I know Ivermectin works it you know it
worked on me it worked on Friends uh
even from like a nurse saying you know
she gave it to patients and she saw them
recover
I guess the
because covid is not as deadly and
serious as it was made out to be it you
know it gives
more power to to this these kind this
kind of uh
anecdotes and that people would normally
be able to recognize it as anecdotes
because
most people not over 99 of people
recover just fine and so you would have
so many cases of people getting better
when given you know whether it's
hydroxyl cocaine or Ivermectin
um
anyway that's just a
thought I yeah no it's it's absolutely
the problem with anecdote the
frustrating thing right anecdote
especially in the case of an infectious
disease from which people recover how do
you know whether the drug you took made
you better or not it's every bit as
foolish as people saying well I got
coveted after getting the vaccine and it
would have been so much worse if I
didn't exactly that's true yeah
absolutely no right yeah yeah and
because most people do would not don't
have uh severe cases infections or
reactions right and so natural so most
people who got the vaccine would not
have had a severe reaction anyway
right so yeah yep so you know in you
know I have taken Ivermectin when I have
had covet and I believe it has had a
dramatic effect but I don't use that I
don't report that as evidence because
the truth is I can't know right yeah
however I would point out that there are
other kinds of evidence that don't
function that way for example
where are the doctors who have treated
patients early with a sufficient dose of
ivermectin for covid and don't think it
works
there are lots of doctors who have never
used it because they don't think it
works and they still don't think it
works but the doctors who have used it
seem to think it works that's an
interesting pattern is it possible for
doctors to fool themselves yes although
in many cases we're talking about some
of the most highly published people in
their fields these are people who are
well versed in science who are
thoroughly aware of the danger of
anecdote and so I put a very high weight
on the clinical experience of people who
have tried lots of things and seen
plenty that don't work and think that
hydroxychloroquine and Ivermectin both
do
yeah
I uh
I know you this is your mate one of your
big uh topics of Interest
um
I always find it interesting to hear you
speak on it I'm gonna attempt to change
the topic no no I I I here's the thing
it's not really my topic of interest and
a topic of interest of yours not the I
mean let me fill in why and then you'll
see why it will automatically do what
you want in terms of change of topic my
belief is that what happened during
covid
reveals the corruption of our system
yeah virtually every institution failed
virtually every piece of advice that you
were given from Something official was
not just wrong but the inverse of true
right they locked you in your home when
you should have been outside right that
was a terrible mistake they gave you a
novel vaccine when you should have been
taking vitamin D right
across the board they did the inverse of
the right thing and we still don't know
why so my point really well we I mean
yeah we can I think it's pretty fair to
say
why if you know I want to know I'm still
not sure I know
well I mean to to sell vaccines
um right even though they were free to
the public the government's coughing up
the cash for it
um so yeah to absolutely to sell
vaccines I mean and here I mean the
evidence to that I see that shows that I
mean it's
seems kind of obvious but one um
specific instance was you're probably
from are you familiar with how
natural immunity was removed from the
whose website
so that tells me and also the timing of
it Brett the timing of it
um it was removed
I believe just uh before or just after
um the Pfizer's first uh press release
on trials for the vaccine so I mean it's
just the correlation's pretty pretty
amazing there
um and then all of a sudden they removed
it completely they did bring it back uh
maybe a month or so later
after the emergency authorization
right and it's just so amazing and uh
they also brought it back
um
on New Year's Eve when most people
wouldn't really notice and also
um and they did and they also brought it
back they had a different you know
context saying that they do not think or
advocate for treating or curing the
pandemic with natural immunity but
vaccines so they they changed that
that's when they brought it back of
course okay but let's go back to your
premise
they did it to sell vaccines
that makes logical sense to me
but I find it so shocking
given the danger involved in inoculating
people with this highly novel gene
therapy technology
the idea that they would
attempt to inoculate children
that they would push to have those
so-called vaccines put on the regular
vaccine schedule
that they would do so on the basis of
very little testing in some cases no
human testing at all
that is a level of indifference to harm
to other people's children that I find
very difficult to imagine
so are you saying that the the policy
that you saw simply makes sense to you
as people who don't care that they are
killing innocence
well I think the majority of people
advocating for vaccines for everybody
um
don't you know are not motivated to sell
more vaccines but I mean certainly we I
mean there's no question Pfizer is
motivated
by profit
um
to sell more vaccines
and you know and then those in power you
know it's great political uh tool you
know it was a great weapon to wield
against Donald Trump right he's weak on
covid and covet is this you know
incredibly dangerous thing that's
life-threatening to everybody
was the way it was you know kind of
framed
um so that's another motivation right
just political reasons
um
when as long as if you can fear Monger
if people are afraid they're easier to
control
um
and you and you keep your eyes glued to
the to the new the news more clicks
there's all these factors
um
yeah yeah I mean I see them too and you
know I've I know that I have said
many times that whatever motivated this
policy it is clear that the people who
architected it are completely
indifferent to the death of other people
yeah
um yeah so there is a part of me that
it's I think the problem is intuitively
it doesn't feel like it could be true
but logically speaking there's really no
next nearest competitor the in fact the
least worst explanation is that this was
simple greed
their explanations worse than that but
you know the floor is
they did it to sell vaccines and they
didn't care
who got hurt which uh is an amazing fact
to be if that's really what's going on
it is an amazing thing to have witnessed
terrifying but is it's happened before
hasn't it uh with the h1n
uh flu right
swine flu the vaccines right well yes on
the other hand in Prior cases we've
pulled vaccines from the market because
of safety signals that were a lot less
impressive than the one that the MRNA
vaccines generated so yeah yes it's not
nothing here is unprecedented including
indifference to the suffering and death
of other people but the scale of it the
scale of it
it boggles the mind
yeah
yeah I mean it all happened on a global
scale I mean you had the who
sane
quote nobody is safe
until everybody is safe that was echoed
in the in the U.S media that's what it's
one of the mashups I've got in the works
and they just kept her pretty nobody is
safe
when the reality was at
99.5 percent of people were safe
at its worst almost everybody was safe
from the beginning and worse again this
is something that you won't be in a
position to to comment on in all
likelihood but
if we had done nothing
right no including not applied the very
good drugs that we had available to us
if we had simply done nothing
there is a pretty good likelihood that
this thing would have controlled itself
that now that we understand that the
proliferation of variance is actually
driven by this very narrow vaccination
campaign
we you know not only is the entire
pandemic likely a self-inflicted wound
with a laboratory Escape but what we did
compounded that self-inflicted when we
keep you know we keep inflicting new
wounds on ourselves and I I really I
think the
most important question in the entire
pandemic might be
uh
how much of the harm that was done here
after the thing was already spreading
was uh theatrogenic medically induced
harm
that yes the cost would have been very
high many would have died
but would it have been more or fewer who
died if we had done nothing and just
simply allowed natural immunity to
accumulate
yeah
but Matt I have derailed your attempt to
change the subject in my attempt to show
you why it didn't really need to change
because we were headed there anyway so
why don't we uh why don't we force the
matter you make mashups that reveal
propaganda I think I forgot to say at
the top of the podcast that you have
been working of late with Matt taibi one
of my favorites one of the last great
journalists uh on uh what does he call
racket news yep now racket news formerly
TK news yeah formerly TK so
um tell me about
how you ended up making mashups where
you see it going what what as a
non-mash-up guy what should I know
well it started honestly I wasn't that
into politics until 2016 I think a lot
of people had a similar experience
um
and I I just started seeing stuff
like just how uh corrupt and unfair the
media was
um at that at the time I saw them you
know misframing Bernie Sanders
constantly
um and clearly propping up Hillary
Clinton one blatant example was you know
I went to like a see it CNN site and
they had a they had a mashup or or
highlight reel for Hillary Clinton after
the first debates there were several
candidates at that point they hadn't
made a highlight reel for any other
candidate that's just one example and
um anyway I I could see
um Bernie Sanders
speeches and his consistency over the
years
Andy was just totally not how
his enemies were framing him you know
they tried to smear him as sexist racist
you know all the usual ad hominem
attacks
and unlike most people
because he had been in politics for so
long there was this recorded history
where you could show it's like no that's
you know he he was a civil
rights activist got arrested you know
protesting segregation segregated
housing
um anyway most people
I don't think are that into politics
understandably it's understandably it's
kind of disgusting and condensing
um you know history
was just kind of a way that I could
share
um history with people
um
because most people they're not going to
sit through a full Bernie Sanders speech
but after you see a little you know an
intriguing highlight you know maybe you
would now
the whole Bernie Sanders
thing that there's a
a whole story that goes goes along with
that I don't know if you're aware but
um I was eventually
asked to work for the Sanders campaign
I did not know this okay so my videos
consistently outperformed the actual
campaign
and so they finally called me in
in this is in 2019 at this point
and they said we love your videos we
want you to come to you know want to
hire this is the campaign manager
uh fast Shakur at the time
and
so I go to headquarters now honestly
this is something
that
I had wanted for a while I mean I was
making these videos for nothing and if I
could get paid to do this
you know that was like kind of a a dream
come true
but when I went to the headquarters the
first thing
I asked so what's the first you know
what's the first project you'd have me
do after they asked what projects I was
interested in making
or had wanted to do myself
and they said the first thing they're
going to have me do or they would have
me do is edit
videos that are that I had already made
that were so successful that they had
reached out to hire me
how crazy is that
it it's just that's insane
and
they specifically they wanted me to cut
out like a clip of Trevor Noah where I'm
kind of making fun of Trevor Noah and
showing how how he's kind of
bullshitting about Bernie Sanders
uh and now overall I would say Trevor
Noah might have been an ally of the
Sanders campaign and that's probably why
they wanted me to cut out this little
criticism but it's like he was wrong
here he's and he's jabbing you like why
not jab him back anyway
um so I got really uneasy because I'm
sitting there in the headquarters
uh being offered a job but I'm like I
don't like this is just weird like
um
so
I mean long
story less long I know I've been reading
going after a while but
uh eventually they you know they they
promised me I'd have creative uh control
which was my big concern right I'm like
and because it did because the fact that
they wanted to cut already successful
videos up
didn't seem like they would give me
creative controls but they promised me
that over the phone eventually and I
said okay
then
and this is a
a story that you might be able to relate
to I think
um
okay an old video an old remix mashup uh
got uncovered so they had hired me to be
creative editor
and then all of a sudden when they found
out that I had a history of creative
editing
they thought they got worried because it
could be offensive
and pressured me to resign
um interesting yeah it's it's incredible
now interestingly this this um
remix or edit that
was of concern to them was well I I
recut
Martin Luther King Juniors I Have a
Dream speech I cut granular editing so
by the phoneme uh to totally recreate
basically you would call it a deep fake
now but I did it like 10 years before
deep fakes was a thing and it was I it
was documented in the description
um
this is I understand this might offend
people but this is to remind people how
easy it is that the media can be
manipulated
um anyway it was It was obviously a
parody comedy
I have a wet dream instead of I have a
dream right so and so he had it I had
him saying I had a dream to do drugs I
have a dream to have sex okay
and and so this was like deemed too
offensive
um
and I was cancels I was effectively
canceled and which is
yeah so so there's so many funny things
about this because at the time
Sanders was um
stomping and advocating
for a job guarantee so this is so so you
guaranteed everybody a job except the
one guy who did a better job than his
entire video Department I mean and it
just
uh but
ah
anyway I had all these uh
FL I did have flashbacks of your
experience which I observed you know in
in you know podcasts and videos where
you explained it and where it was
recorded that whole thing
yeah
and I remember seeing that and I was
just so
um I it really troubled me
and I
yeah and then yeah it just it came for
for me too
um I mean a little differently but still
the same like kind of crazy cancel
culture
well that's that's interesting on
several different levels one
there is a
I don't know let's call it an ironic
stupidity
where people see something like what
you're doing
and they think this is fantastic right
and what they're resonating with is the
authenticity of what you're doing right
and then as soon as they have you their
point is okay but this makes us a little
nervous and it's like look
either the authenticity is good or
you're going to start chopping it away
and we're gonna end up right back where
you were right exactly at some point you
take the risk of the authenticity and
the fact is
you know for Heather and me
a big part of why we have a large
audience is that it's just pretty
obvious we're not faking right we're
real people trying to do the right thing
uh and so the point is the the rarer
authenticity becomes the more prized it
is so when people do recognize that yeah
how terrible would it be if you took
Trevor Noah at a task Trevor Noah screws
up every now and again right taking him
to task is a way of it's a kind of
feedback in fact
um it's useful
but the other thing a point I wanted to
make is
it is funny that their instinct to
um you know to take
you this you know Wild Horse and tame
you right so that you could do your cool
Wild Horse thing but in a completely
controlled way
in fact a cautionary tale for what
happened to Bernie Sanders yes right
yeah because Bernie Sanders was
you think what you like about his
politics but he was an absolute Renegade
to be uh you know an admitted socialist
in the U.S Senate for how many years I
mean that is not easy to do this was
somebody
who was uh truly a Maverick and quite
capable and today
he's almost unrecognizable I think
because something got in his ear and was
like Bernie
it's too much of that too much of this
and now he's just another Democrat yeah
yeah
it's tragic
it is it is I mean I was you know
obviously that's what attracted me to
him and you know
probably you know a huge part of his
supporters is he I mean he was he really
was independent he was critical of both
the Republicans and the Democrats as as
any right-thinking person would be would
have to be in light of the corruption of
those two parties yeah but not not
anymore like you said yep
um
so okay let me ask you this you've
obviously been uh how old a person are
you
I'm in my 30s you're in your 30s well
that's a nice way of saying about being
older yeah you are getting older but as
they say it beats the alternatives
um but all right you're in your 30s
you've obviously uh traveled an
interesting Road you've gone from being
a an enthusiastic Bernie supporter
making uh
it's not fan fiction but fan
video mashups to reveal things you've
then been taken inside the mothership
and you've discovered that the rot is
everywhere and reaches everything
where are you now politically do you
mind saying well I mean I've always
considered myself independent
but I mean technically I mean I'm from
DC so therefore naturally I was a
registered Democrat
um
and
I mean that's that's where I am I mean
I'm still a registered Democrat I don't
identify as one I don't really I didn't
vote last uh election
um
I just consider I did not vote I
couldn't do it I I mean
I mean honestly there's so many
what I feared
you know kind of came true I thought
Biden could even be worse uh mainly
because
I mean I asked the question to myself
like who's the most dangerous president
the one who the media is you know
critical of all day every day or the one
that the media just gives a pass yep and
yeah I just I just couldn't vote I I was
I knew either way I was gonna regret it
and so I just
yeah all right well I want to I want to
try to convince you as a proxy for many
in the audience who will feel the same
way that
um your thinking is correct but that
your strategy is wrong
okay
um
either way you had a mistake on your
hands right I think lots of us arrived
at that conclusion neither of these
answers was acceptable both of them were
a terrible terrible risk
problem is
most people
don't vote
and most of them don't vote not because
they have a sophisticated position that
says actually you haven't given me a
decent option yet they're just tuned out
now maybe they're tuned out after never
having seen a decent option and so
they're just not paying attention but
the problem is when you don't vote you
actually don't hurt the Beast that has
taken over our system
it's perfectly comfortable with a tiny
fraction of people voting as long as
people that it likes win which is why of
course the primaries are rigged right it
may well be the general election is fair
or ish right it may be that there's no
tampering but the point is the parties
rigged the primaries to make sure that
whoever gets in there it doesn't really
matter it all does the machines and
third parties are you know blocked out
third parties are blocked out by the
Lesser evil paradox
and so anyway my point to you would be
what you don't want to do is join the
apathetic
in not voting you cannot help but become
indistinguishable from the apathetic
in voting for something
doesn't matter whether it's viable but
in voting for something that the major
parties hate
you are delivering a message which says
my vote is available to somebody who
will deliver something meaningfully good
to me somebody who will protect people
who deserve it somebody who will offer a
vision for the future my vote is
available that
is the incentive that will drive
something to challenge the system and I
will say as much as Donald Trump was a
uh
a terrible result as much as a man with
Donald Trump's temperament should never
have been in the white house he did do
civilization a huge favor
and that favor was he demonstrated that
the duopoly could be beaten because he
did
yes he's not who the GOP wanted in fact
there's a strong argument to be made
that he was in some sense chosen by
Hillary Clinton
because she thought she could easily
beat him that's right the Pied Piper
strategy
yeah that's exactly what they elevated
uh Trump they elevated Trump but anyway
he did demonstrate that it could be
beaten it needs to be beaten by somebody
who knows what to do with the power once
he or she gets it
um you know and I would you know Trump
did some decent stuff he but again
temperamentally he was just not right
for the jobs and and will never be but
um but anyway I would advise you and
anybody who thinks that not voting is
what you do when you haven't been given
a viable choice that makes any sense you
don't want to join the apathetic you
want to make it clear that you are
voting against the duopoly that's that's
yeah and to be clear if I did see any
good option I would have voted like in
2016 I did vote for Jill Stein I do
um I mean honestly if there's just okay
all a candidate has to do that's is just
like say I will pardon Edward Snowden
like that just makes so much freaking
sense
and yet nobody's do so and then Frank
and Jill Stein actually said she would
do that it's like okay you're She's All
That Makes Her Like levels above anybody
else because it's just such so common
sense
um
um so yeah I mean how can
like the saying goes like if
um
if telling the truth is a lie right
you're being or a crime then you're
being ruled by criminals
um and so gee it's just to have someone
recognize that obvious truth
I will vote for you yeah
well these are I hate to use the phrase
interesting times but they are
interesting times in part because you
know
I guess you and I might be in a little
uh competition here I I thought of
myself as the world's most reluctant
Democrat but it sounds like uh maybe
that title is at least going to be
contested by your reluctance over the
Democratic Party
um but you know let me ask you a
question I look at the Democratic party
and you know I'm older than you are by
quite a bit I'm 54.
uh I've spent my whole adult life as a
Democrat I'm still a registered Democrat
for some reason I can't quite explain to
myself
um but I look at this party and I think
there's not a single
likable person in it
it's not I mean you know lots of Voters
who are likable but in terms of people
in the party who I think oh yeah if only
you know could that person make it all
the way it's like I can't name anybody
that I want to see in a high office
which is
stunning because
what used to be true
the Democratic party had
a lock
on the go-to strategy if what you want
to do is win
the Democrats had the go-to move which
was you represent working people yeah
right they never did a great job of it
not during my lifetime but they did some
sort of job they advocated for things
that would be good for workers not all
the time but the point is they actually
shifted strategies and they became a
second corporate party rather than a
party of working people and it's like
well okay
what that tells me is they are more
interested in the power that they win
than they are in wielding it for
anything useful
because if they wanted to win they could
go back to representing people and they
would instantly become popular
yeah right so we have two unpopular
parties because nobody represents the
American people and no room for a third
party that just simply said hey you know
what as long as the jobs open we'll
represent the people
you know that's not allowed because
you'll you'll elect the greater evil
well I get it it's a trap
it's a trap that you've set
yeah
yep
do you
um are you gonna do that what was that
uh you know call for a third party thing
that you did that got censored yeah
Unity 2020.
um let's put it this way there are
people from Unity 2020 who are pretty
excited about uh a strategy
I am reluctant
because
I know something about the power that
opposes anything that might work
and what I'm waiting for is to be
convinced that there is a viable move in
other words I don't want to Tilt at
windmills but I would gladly take a risk
even a big one
uh on a plan that might rescue us from
the death spiral
so anyway I'm not yet committed to
either do something or not do something
needs to be done and frankly you know
Unity 2020
was I believe the right idea in the
following sense
the the core of unity 2020 for those who
who haven't heard of it was that it was
a plan that structurally
neutralized the ideological bias
in third partyism
and so we neutralized the idea of the
Lesser evil
um by virtue of the fact that we had a
Fail-Safe that we would pull the plug if
we couldn't win which is ultimately
um what we did
and we also structured the plan so that
it drew from both right and left in a
way Innovative things knew that they
were not going to to uh to lose as a
result of this so it didn't draw heavily
from either side it drew we actually
tested this we tested the people who
were supporters
um and it turned out uh that it actually
gave almost no bias and the tiny little
bias that it gave was in favor of Biden
rather than Trump so even though the
Democrats were the ones pissed off about
it
um they were wrong that it was you know
a spoiler for trump it was the opposite
if anything and it wasn't and it was
built not to be so you know it's
structurally neutralized this by
proposing
within the Constitution without having
to change anything structural
that we draft somebody from the center
left and somebody from the center right
under the agreement that they would flip
a coin to figure out who was running for
president and who was running for vice
president
that if elected that they would govern
as a team that they would discuss
everything and reach a consensus between
the two and only in cases where they
could not reach a consensus on what was
in the interest of the American people
or in the case that there wasn't time a
decision that had to be made in a matter
of minutes and you couldn't gather or
something like that only in those two
cases would the person in the
president's chair
rule independently
and then after four years the roles
would flip and the idea was that that
was just a way of neutralizing the game
theoretic problems with a third party
now the fascinating thing is this was a
small effort
but it definitely got the attention of
people in power to the point that I was
thrown off Facebook even though I wasn't
using Facebook the Twitter account of
unity 2020 was suspended on false
pretenses it has recently been
reinstated by musk but the previous
management of Twitter absolutely refused
to reinstate it so the point is power
understood what kind of threat this was
it never got to a position where it was
of a magnitude that could be that threat
but somehow power realized
that if you neutralized the Lesser evil
problem that actually people would
listen and that basically the only
argument for the duopoly is that you
don't have an alternative as soon as you
do people will flee in droves
yeah I I mean I noticed the same
obviously there was the same fear uh
over there's always the same fear over
third parties but in 16 in 2016 uh in
particular you know Jill Stein was and
you know Gary Johnson to another degree
too uh were seen as threats
and I and they you know you mentioned
being censored your your third party
project being censored
um
I had a video uh exposing PBS's
censorship of Jill Stein and that was
censored removed without any
notification
in uh um and and that's so this is
before
um you know they would even give you a
notification or maybe they were supposed
to when they did they did it I mean it
was super sketchy
like
um your the situation with uh
Unity 2020 being censored it's just so
sketchy um and the only way I found out
I mean I guess I could have gone to my
page and seen that it was and it was no
longer there but all the people uh
whose walls Facebook walls that had been
removed from
they had a notification from where it
was that they had been at violation of
community standards it didn't violate
any Community standards none whatsoever
but um
and I I you know made sure to document
that because you know it sounds
crazy just totally
removed no explanation and then when an
explanation was given to other people
that didn't make any sense
um
but I got all the screenshots from
dozens and dozens of people who shared
it
well I think most people do not because
most people never initiate something
that violates one of the unwritten
sacred rules
most people have no idea
that yes they are free but they are free
in the sense that animals in a zoo are
free right like a chimpanzee can decide
how to spend its time in the zoo but it
can't decide to leave the zoo and what
we have is a political system
in which we get to choose our leaders as
long as they are from a slate that has
been vetted by something that knows it
will be taken care of
right that's not the Democracy that was
envisioned at all in fact it's the
inverse of it right it feels it's almost
worse than an authoritarian uh structure
that is inherited or one through
military force and the reason is because
the false sense of security that our
leaders are the ones we chose and we
chose them on the basis of what they
will do for us that false impression
is uh it is slowly choking the life out
of the West
right we are now at a point where we are
actually sabotaging the essential
functions at the core of our
civilization and we don't really realize
it nor do we realize that we are
condemned to stay on this trajectory
because we feel like well in principle
somebody who's good at governing could
Arise at any moment and they could be
very popular because they would say
things that would resonate with people
and they would rise to the head of one
of these parties and then they would
Ascend to the office and then they would
do things no no no that's all impossible
you don't know were you telling me that
it does not be apathetic Brad
no no well I'm not telling you to be
apathetic I'm telling you do not spend
somebody is playing rope-a-dope with us
yeah and they are spending our energy on
a horse race in which we don't have a
horse
right we are all involved in this horse
race but the point is our our horses
have all been barred or shot or whatever
and so no I'm not telling you to be
apathetic but I am telling you
um well you did say it's impossible to
you know work your way through the you
know for a good person representing the
people to rise up uh through politics
basically well I should probably say it
slightly more carefully I should say
nearly impossible no I believe it is
functionally impossible to do it through
the parties I believe Trump demonstrated
you could go around the party you could
decapitate a party temporarily
and that's plausible apparently I
wouldn't have said so but it is
apparently plausible well he didn't go
around it he went through it he took it
over right yeah I would say he went
around it and you know stepped in front
of it and became its head
um which you know
the thing is Bernie was in a position to
do the same thing same thing but he he
held back a bit Trump went all out
Sanders held back a bit well you know I
don't know either man but I would say
the difference is that
Trump is
the kind of player who
understands everything to be a
legitimate move in the game
and Sanders is constrained by
his morals some some moral code that
limits what moves he can make which
allowed
Hillary Clinton who I believe is much
more trump-like we'll play any move
as a legitimate move in the game it
allowed her to drive him into
irrelevance and frankly to paint people
like you and me
as Bernie Bros remember that yeah yeah
crazy that just came out of nowhere I
was just like wait
suddenly this is about
being a dude
I thought this was about like working
people getting the shaft and somebody
wants to fix that they had to paint a
working class movement as sexist I mean
and racist and so bad and the funny
thing is and it's you know it's reused
it's used every cycle practically I mean
apparently during the 2018 sorry 2008
um Hillary Clinton campaign
pushed this Narrative of the Obama boys
online
yeah that's that's gross yeah yeah well
so but okay this this actually then is
right back in uh in your area of
expertise because it looks to me
like there's a set of epithets
that are so terrifying to people they're
socially terrifying things that if you
are accused of them cause most people to
buckle because they do not know how to
field the accusation right the thing
that uh captured people's attention
about my confrontation at Evergreen was
that the students said I was a racist
these are students I'd never met by the
way
these students that I'd never met said I
was a racist and I said no I'm not and
most people couldn't imagine how a white
Professor was going to survive just
simply saying no that's not true right
so the point is there was a question
about can you figure out how to stare
down a bad accusation right and that bad
accusation can be conspiracy theorist it
can be anti-vaxxer
it can be racist it can be transphobe it
can be Bernie bro it can be apparently
Obama boy right
um so I guess the point is at some point
does this it's a single trick there's an
epithet it sounds like the end of your
social life if it gets appended to you
and so everybody is bending over
backwards to make sure it doesn't get
directed at them
right if
they keep doing this and then it turns
out that a a certain number of us figure
out how to stare it down and at B the
People Who Stare it down turn out to be
uh
safer or uh insulate themselves from
some kind of authoritarian oppression
then at some point people are going to
realize ah they're epithets they don't
mean anything right they've robbed these
I mean some of these things
we need to be able to accuse racists of
racism right how dare you burn that one
up accusing people who aren't guilty of
it of being racist you've just let all
the racists off the hook right how could
you right you want to abuse Nazi you
want to let Nazis off the hook because
that's what you're doing right so I
don't know what do you think are the are
the epithets eventually going to lose
their power when one after another turns
out to be political garbage
I think they are losing their power but
it might just be you know I worry that
it's just
you know my network my right uh
re recognizes that it's but
there's still huge bubbles of the
population that
you know the the you know one of the
bigger ones the Democratic party bubble
a lot of anybody that's still a part of
that party they still believe that stuff
that you know they take the bait every
time otherwise they wouldn't be in the
Democratic party cult anymore I mean I
understand you're registered but we're
not really in you know identify as
Democrats that's the question when I
hear
that
um
my concern over mRNA vaccines
is going to make me an Untouchable from
the point of view of
New York Times reading NPR listening
Democrats
my thing my feeling is
that is is that's a zero cost right with
the exception of some very old people
who have read the New York Times who
read it back when it was a newspaper who
listened to NPR back when it was public
broadcasting before these things were
pure propaganda Outlets all right
there's some people you know some very
old folks who can't seem to get over the
loss of those properties and they still
believe in them but
in terms of
one's interactions in life generally
apart from their older relatives
I don't
I don't need to make sense to New York
Times readers those people are
inherently confused in fact if I'm
running my life around trying to make
sense to a New York Times reader then
I'm gonna end up like Bernie Sanders
where suddenly I'm useless
yeah right so so I guess the point is
the I think a lot of the
threat
is
in people's minds that the the cost of
actually confronting these epithets is
small because frankly a lot more people
are aware that these are nonsense than
you are led to believe yeah yeah and it
and it I mean honestly it almost gives
you uh more credibility now because it
shows that you are perceived as a threat
to you know the establishment
and I mean I'll say you know when I was
canceled
you know it did seem like it was being
um
you know shamed and attacked by more
people than it actually was I mean
privately many people many people were
you know
knew it was and they
uh sympathized with me privately
um
so that was I mean it's a shame where
people couldn't say it publicly but at
least that did at least you know show
them show me that
this is just you know appearance on the
surface you know most people or at least
a lot of people can see through this and
I guess every time someone
just responds rationally calmly like you
did and just asking you know
basic questions you know then they
go on to expose themselves
as you know often the ones who are
bigoted
um
it's funny like
I mean that that's the the way hatred is
expressed now
is is by accusing the hated of being
hateful
and when yeah like I said when you
respond as you did just like calmly and
clearly it really exposes uh the scam
yeah you know
the more I think about it
when I was confronted by students again
people I had never met
leveling an accusation that I personally
knew had no merit
the thing that
well a the first thing is
they confronted me with my class people
I did know
and I think it took me months to realize
this but I think they were expecting my
class to defect on video right because
of course
students accusing a white professor of
racism
you know in 2017
surely you're gonna find people saying
yeah and you know you're gonna have lots
of disgruntled students or whatever and
of course not a single one of my
students defected because they knew me
and they knew it was garbage too and all
of the students that I had had in years
prior didn't affect either for the same
reason
but it was also true
that in class we were talking about
racism and where it comes from and what
it has to do with Evolution and what
needs to be true in order for it never
to rear its ugly head again you know
um
and I also had my own
history I could look back at my own
history and I could check you know do
they have a point no they don't have a
point I I can prove they don't have a
point
so
what I'm getting at is
I was in a very unusual position when
they leveled that accusation at me which
was that I knew no matter how many
rounds we went
there was nothing for them to find they
weren't going to find a shred of
evidence that this was true and I had a
whole lot of evidence that they knew
nothing about from my earlier history
that I could have brought to bear if
need be to establish that their
accusation was nonsense but
who has that that's rare yeah and what
they're doing by effectively
creating hyper awareness of race at
every moment is preventing people from
living a life that could generate that
evidence
I was lucky to generate lots of
interracial interactions you know
in a context where everybody knew that
the objective was to make race
less important
right everybody every good person
understood that race had been too
important and that it needed to become
unimportant and that although
you can debate where we are relative to
a colorblind society that that's where
we should be headed right
so in that world
I had lots of experiences that I could
point to
somebody who grew up 20 years later
would have had
experiences in a world where race was
always
charged
right
and so the point is part of the
Diabolical aspect of the strategy here
is that it prevents people from
um
living a life that would tell them that
what they were being accused of was
nonsense so I think lots of people have
self-doubt maybe we're shouting yeah
that I'm a racist then maybe I am that's
what they think
yeah no really I mean it's
yeah especially people who are
you know open-minded which is I think a
good important type of person to have
and you'll be like oh like you said oh
did I do something wrong and uh and
honestly like I you know ask myself that
when I was being all these accusations
were being hurled against me
um and it happened so fast fast Brett
like I was given no time to even defend
myself like
um and I mean I I had drafted an apology
the Sanders campaign leaked it to a
report I said I said this is for you to
say yes I'm I'm happy to resign
because you know I don't want to work
with I I already explained why I had my
like reservations about working for them
when they were really going to give me
creative control but anyway
um
they it got so the apology which I said
was still just a draft get gets leaked
to the Press but anyway after
um there was all within like an hour of
being pressured to resign and within an
hour I had no time
I looked back at the videos
I was like that ain't bad that really
ain't bad uh and so it is kind of
imagining anyway that just
um well but with big another big what
makes it so diabolic
as you were saying
in addition to what you were saying is
that it is so like you can't prove a
negative right or it's very difficult to
yep
it's very difficult to
um which is part of what they count on
and they also count on the game theory
which is
they point this super weapon at you
and the idea is we'll pull the trigger
unless you demonstrate
your subordination to us in which case
we'll move on to somebody else
and so
staring it down is terrifying
not staring it down causes it to spread
it becomes effectively contagious
because each person capitulates and
drives them onto the next person and at
some level
you just gotta stand up and say no
that's nonsense right yeah so if you had
it to do over if I understand your story
correctly it was the
um
the ironic re-editing of the Martin
Luther King Dream speech that caused the
uh campaign to go after you
there all these comedy videos I mean
like which I mean like a word like oh I
used I called myself Brett oh
oh dear God you know I
um I used the word gay oh so I mean
sacrilegious stuff like so all of it was
you know nothing Burgers
um and the campaign didn't even specify
like what it was they just saw that some
um Anonymous Twitter account was
smearing me and that just made him go
crazy now until they had you know
sounded the alarm to me I was very
calmly responding with you know to to
these accusations
um I did do have you know if someone
wanted to to frame that oh I'm racist
and hate Martin Luther King I mean it's
very easy for me to disprove that
luckily because I've made a dozen videos
celebrating Martin Luther King's life so
I was just able to show you know that
like yeah really racist here's some
videos of of my racism you know
celebrating Martin Luther King James
um so I was doing that calmly but then
when I get that call like that really
um alarmed me too
and if I could do it over again I think
I I should have pushed back
on the Sanders campaign
I felt at the time like I said I had my
reservations of working for them because
I had been given all these hints that
they weren't actually going to let me do
my thing and be creative
um so that might that's part of why I
gave in without a a fight because I was
like f you know screw this
um but also it's like who am I to you
know
say no you need to work with you need to
hire me it's like I can't you know I'm
not in the position of power to do that
but still I should have
tried to push back but he wasn't even
having it like he wasn't open to uh
um like he literally mentioned he said
he thought I should resign
like before he even heard my cider like
my response to to this I mean
all right well I uh you didn't ask but
nevertheless nevertheless nevertheless I
still should have pushed back and can I
I have thought about this so I can get
be actually specific like how I would
have pushed back good
um
it was so um okay so he comes he calls
me this is the campaign manager of the
Sanders campaign
says he's got three reporters you know
hounding them about these old videos
and I should have been well first of all
like have you seen the videos fast like
what is wrong with them
um and also point out the irony
that the video that I had made that
finally got them to to contact me
personally and try to bring me on was a
video exposing how the media is smearing
Bernie Sanders
so I would juxtapose the smears from
MSNBC and CNN about you know suggesting
that he's racist and sexist and I would
juxtapose that to stuff that obviously
showed that that was him at
like a women's women's March and I mean
his history you know protesting civil
rights okay so I'm like hold on like so
why wouldn't you let's see so I would
just say hold on you want more people to
see this video
why don't you uh oh he he mentioned that
it was he was worried because one of the
reporters from NBC
said it was going to be a debate
question about me being on the game
which sounds crazy it's hard to believe
but hey there's they ask pretty dumb
irrelevant debate questions to try and
smear some people so if they did that
what do you do Fez you would just say uh
no it's a ridiculous smear and in fact I
recommend everybody go see the video he
just made and that's why I hired him to
be on the campaign so you make you use
it to your benefit if they want to give
you more attention fight take advantage
of it and Trump did that uh Bernie
Sanders campaign failed to do that in
this case I would also bring up
something which I was not aware of at
the time which I think is a very
interesting
relevant story and that is that the
uh in the during the previous campaign
in 2016
there was a Bernie Sanders staffer maybe
senior advisor
his name was Chuck Rosa
he
was actually uh convicted of a crime
um Union embezzlement so he was you know
stealing money from a union that he
represented it's like
and how did the campaign manager defend
him
it's so interesting Brett because you
look at the article and the campaign
manager was like he's a great person
that was in the past you know he's a
valuable part of the team we're gonna
move forward with him
and
I would just say how could you
come on what I did was a joke this was
an actual crime that contradicts your
entire you know political messaging
you're supposed you say you're
representing unions you're against
corruption and this is a guy who has a
crime where he was stealing you know he
was a corrupt union leader
and I would I think that would be worth
poison to him I would love to hear his
reaction to that to like how do you
explain that inconsistency
um and that brings up a whole an
interesting subject
I'm curious you if you have any thoughts
on it but it's Society this just that
experience it may be recognize and worry
is society
recognizing now jokes as more toxic than
actual crime
it seems like that in some cases which
and that's very scary
what do you think I think a couple
things one I hear a theme in a couple of
your
uh
uh and a couple of your stories in not
voting in the last election and in this
case where you felt there was no hope in
fighting back against this bad
accusation
and now you wish you had said some
things to the person who was uh
who was going after you and I I wanted
to
tell you something that I learned before
the well sorry to cut you up such good I
did you know respond to the people you
know making an accusations but this was
the my employer at the time
you know right um a little different but
yeah no no I'm not saying you didn't
respond but but I hear a kind of you say
you wish you had done something
different you wish yeah I wish I had
pushed back more
um from inside yeah okay so
what I wanted to point out to you is
something that I learned actually from
Jordan Peterson before
Evergreen melted down I learned I didn't
know Jordan I just was watching what was
happening to him and because the storm
was gathering around me it resonated
because I saw somebody
uh behave
uh admirably in a situation that I
thought I might find myself in
what I learned there's a famous video
maybe it's the first famous video for
for for Jordan
where he is being confronted by a mob
uh at the University of Toronto I guess
I've seen it you've seen it and he's
sitting in the front of the
room supposed to give a speech and
people are using air horns and shouting
and you can't hear anything he can't he
can't give his speech right
is that the video you've seen I was
thinking outside where like a mob of
people it's the same same incident but
earlier I guess okay but okay
what I realized was that Jordan
was absolutely defeated in that room
he could not say a syllable that anybody
could understand
however what happened in that room did
not matter
that the room is not the room
the real room was the internet where we
looked in and watched this man
uh
retain his composure
in the face of this absolutely atrocious
treatment
and so I I started using the phrase the
room is not the room do not mistake the
room that you are in for the important
context of what's happening to you
and so in your story what I hear is
probably there wasn't much you could
have done that would have changed your
fate at the Sanders campaign
on the other hand if you thought of that
as
part of your history
that would end up mattering that you
would end up talking about it on a
podcast like this one
then you might have
um
behaved in a way that would not have
changed the outcome but would have uh
allowed you to utilize it to Greater and
more positive effect by virtue of it
demonstrating the hypocrisy inside and
you you know if the essential point is
look you know I wanted to go work for
the Bernie Sanders campaign because I
believed in Bernie Sanders and when I
got there here's what I encountered and
this is what I learned from it right
then that's very worthwhile even if it's
not technically productive in the moment
just like voting for somebody who can't
win if it says hey my vote's on offer if
you guys can figure out how to you know
create a party that is worth voting for
that also in the moment it looks futile
but a futile
but in the end I don't think it is
because you know a majority of us are
either
um not voting because we're pissed off
or voting reluctantly and very eager to
have something better to vote for right
that is a political revolution if
anybody can figure out how to deliver
something
the room is not the room
I I did I do recognize and agree like
I feel like I could have
done something more
um
yeah taken a bigger stand
um but I I you know I I still hoped that
you know maybe they would come to their
senses that
you know that Bernie Sanders was still
the you know
the same guy who stood up against the
Iraq War in both Democrats and
Republicans so I still had that hope but
it that should have been I mean
I mean that was a huge wake-up call but
um and I wreck and
I explicitly told him
the campaign manager
don't publish this I'm
I want to think about this more because
I knew it was an opportunity to to
you know say something important
and maybe that he knew what I had in
mind and that's why he leaked to the
Press
uh which is self screwed up well here's
the thing yeah
um you know
as I said I'm a bunch older
maybe I get to be a little bit wiser but
I I feel confident Matt that this is not
the last dumb accusation you will have
to stare down oh sure no I've had yeah
yeah I've had lots of rodeos since then
yeah so that's the thing is you just uh
keep honing your skills and yeah you
know keep going after Goliath
um all right so
where do you see yourself headed
uh do the mashups grow into something
else or
um is this effectively a permanent mode
of attack against the the ever morphing
propaganda machine
would like to make
the
take my mashups to a higher
class which would be a feature
documentary
and I am working on that
um
it's a video about the Kenosha 2020
unrest or a documentary about that
and I mean the concept's really simple I
mean it's it's shocking to me concerning
to me how many people
don't understand what actually happened
while at the same time there's probably
never been a point in human history when
an event was documented which was so
many video recordings so I was like how
is that possible that's crazy
um so
and my style is in the mashups in in
this documentary is just show you what's
happening I don't want to narrate I
don't want to opine I don't want to
interview other people after the fact to
get their opinions of what happened
years ago no just show people what
freaking happened
um and it's really
eye-opening
um
it's an intense cinematic experience and
it just doesn't need the the sit-down
interviews that are so standard with the
documentaries nowadays uh actually uh
um
I'll go you one better I mean this is
the thing maybe that I like most about
your approach
is that you do not tell your audience
what to think about these things and
that that is not because you see them
and it's just obvious
the answer is it is thought provoking to
see these things juxtaposed what could
possibly be true that this juxtaposition
would be would be available
so anyway I love that about your stuff
you are
um basically honoring the intelligence
of your Audience by not summing it up
for them by putting the thing in front
of them and letting them uh connect dots
and think about what those implications
might be it's really I think uh it's a I
don't want to say it's your greatest
strength because I have no idea but it
is certainly a great one
thank you thank you yeah because as you
know I mean God we're in more and more
polarized society and it's just so easy
to unfortunately in common for people to
dismiss something just because of the
person delivering it and so I take you
know like oh the oh he made a video 10
years ago that I heard was terrible or
oh he's conservative he's liberal
um
so yeah I feel like if I just take
myself out of it I don't make myself a
character it's me whoever made it is
irrelevant it's not just look at what's
being shown
like you said and draw your own
conclusions
yep it is uh it is a very beautiful way
of ruling out the possibility that you
are just simply
a super persuasive human hypnotizing
people into whatever right it's like
look these are just these are facts
these things happened in front of a
video camera and here I'm going to
string them together in a way that is
going to force you to recognize there's
more here than meets the eye
um it's uh it's it's powerful to be sure
thanks
um are you in need of a slogan because I
realized early in our conversation that
that was one uh that might fish sure
uh
Matt orifla out of creative control
huh
I'll say yeah not bad one uh I mean one
slogan I came up with is like less group
think more you think it's not so great
though I don't know yeah yeah I don't
know if you need to stick with just one
um yeah yeah
anyway if uh if out of creative control
works for you in any context uh
um you're welcome to it
thank you appreciate it
um all right uh what else uh you know I
when I was a professor I I used to have
this experience where I would um ask
students a question and I would get back
answers that weren't satisfying and then
20 minutes later in the context of some
other conversation they would say
something that I wish they had said when
I had asked him and I would say
why didn't you say that and they'd say
you didn't ask us that I so I started
saying
would you please answer the question I
should have asked you rather than the
one I did ask you so is there anything I
should have asked you
um that I have failed to
uh no I think is this you've asked some
good questions it's been a good
conversation it's you know uh
awesome to to speak with you uh
finally as I said you know I've been
I've inspired you since I saw how you
handled that awful
um you know attack on you in Evergreen
thanks
and I see I mean you did you also asked
me if you could
if I could hear you and if you could
hear me about a hundred times at the
beginning
for technical reasons but uh yeah
the other questions were better
yeah that question uh is not is not the
bad I mean it's very to the point but um
yeah
yeah go ahead I mean I'm really curious
like is it true
I I told you I I was wondering it seems
like I'm seeing like Society make a
bigger deal about jokes than actual
crime is that accurate do you see that
I uh I would put it differently for one
thing we may be in a
in a better phase than we were a couple
years ago but there was a while there
where we were killing off the ability to
make jokes
right and this is terrifying to me
because as an evolutionary biologist who
thinks a lot about humans I know that
jokes are a vital mechanism by which we
navigate difficult topics
and by killing off the ability to make
jokes what we do is we rob ourselves of
exactly the tool that you want to deal
with the difficult stuff right so to the
extent that we have a problem like
race or gender or
economic concentration of wealth you
want people to be able to joke their way
to discoveries about what the nature of
these things is right those jokes are
serious business as it is so anyway
um
that impulse to kill off the jokes is
one thing and then there's a separate
impulse that I think you're recognizing
which is to excuse virtually anything as
long as it seems to be contributing to
your team right both of these are
terrible instincts and so the one
question I have about your formulation
is is it really that we are you know
taking the one thing more seriously than
the other or is this just two separate
bad phenomena that you happen to
encounter at the same moment and it
looks as if they are you know
uh well I mean given what you do that
you juxtapose things and it causes
people to think it's not surprising that
the juxtaposition and time of those two
bad instincts would cause your mind to
erupt with uh concerns but I also I also
wouldn't rule out your formulation I
just don't think
um
yes something like that is happening but
not because the two things are
necessarily connected related yeah yeah
yeah like I see Sam bankman freed like
he gets softball coverage
put Joe Rogan gets hounded you know for
for a comedy podcast
crazy it's crazy one of these people is
obviously mentally decent and you know
contributing to the world and the other
person evaporated a tremendous amount of
wealth lied through his teeth
representing himself as decent as a
cloak for something else it's amazing
they're they're inverse of each other
but you're right the treatment has been
swapped
I just see that
over and over again it seems like ending
I mean in Canada I forget the guy's name
but you know somebody being fined like
thirty thousand dollars for a joke which
was did you hear this story no
I wish I could remember remember the
guy's name but
um can you just tell me what sure sure
he was the joke so terrible or was it
just the timing
it wasn't terrible at all it was just
it's just that the subject of the joke
was
a kid with a disability
um
but the joke was actually about how
people were pretending that he could
the joke was about the comedian's
frustration
with this kid getting so much media
attention for his singing which wasn't
that great and it because allegedly he
was so disabled that he was like so
frail he was going to die and so the
comedian is like he just won't he won't
die like he as if he or wanted him to
die because but this it's he's making a
joke he's like the guy is not as weak as
everyone makes an out to be he was
supposed to die you know five years ago
he's not weak and so it's really you
know he's not really making fun of the
person so much he's making fun of how
people perceive this kid as so weak
again I'm not saying I I didn't hear the
joke I don't know that it was delivered
well I don't know that it was a a joke
that didn't reveal
some sort of
failing on the part of the comedian but
the point is you don't get to persecute
people for uh crossing the line the joke
is about finding out where the line is
right it doesn't mean you can't say I
think there's something wrong with that
guy that he would make that joke right
that's fair but the idea that the law
belongs in here a fine what the hell
right yeah and you know in the hands of
a really good comedian
right uh Louis C.K
with his uh you know
what is it of course but maybe
right the whole of you know the of
course but maybe uh
isn't that the name of one of his
specials or is that a specific oh I
don't know if it's the name of it okay
but it's a sort of a formulation that he
puts together where he sort of goes
through the argument that we all accept
for something and then he says but maybe
and then he gives the really outlandish
thing that nobody is allowed to think
and the point is
you know are we going to forbid Louis CK
from doing that or are we going to
recognize I mean the reason you laugh is
because there's a truth in it that you
recognize in the same moment as
everybody else who's watching
oh we are so dumb
the the comedian's name is Mike Ward
Mike Ward yeah he's ordered to pay forty
two thousand dollars
um and I think it was by like a Canadian
like a Human Rights Council it's like
what so why do they have why do they
have uh jurisdiction is the wrong word
but why under what
uh law is he required to pay anybody who
says he's
definable
some I guess some indecency law or
discrimination
code
um
yeah so it's like a human rights
Tribunal
luckily he did I think he he did
ultimately you know he appealed and
eventually won he won but yeah but it
cost more money you know cost him a ton
of money to do that in time and of
course
I mean it's a good thing he did but like
how many people could can can do that I
mean he was already a successful
comedian
um
at least in Canada
um so he could afford to do that
but
anyway yeah
fascinating
all right well I had not heard that
story that's very disturbing I will look
into it Mike Ward you said yeah
Rogan uh interviewed him
about that and other stuff
um
and yeah like I said I think he came out
on top thankfully good I'm glad to hear
that
may we all be so lucky may we all be so
lucky that's a
I would drink to that but I have um not
only water
drink some water that's how it's more
healthy I drank to it
uh well Matt this has been delightful
I'm very much looking forward to seeing
what you produce uh in the future
hopefully you will find yourself starved
of material because civilization will
start functioning well and there will be
less to juxtapose but I am not going to
hold my breath over that
yeah that's funny I used to whatever did
ways to do more just comedy with alone I
would be you know I get kind of pissed
off like oh damn I was gonna I had that
idea I was gonna make that video but now
if someone else you know makes a video I
was like thank God someone already took
care of it like
foreign
so
um where can people find you
uh youtube.com ORF Rumble
um orphat Rumble uh zero RF on Twitter
zero RF on Twitter
yes
uh yeah I kind of screwed myself with
that but I'd so I have to make sure to
tell people soon
um
so yeah please check me out there
everyone and uh and I mean and on uh
racket news your pieces that's right
there yeah you'll see my work on taibi's
racket news your work on taibi's Record
News and actually
Matt did a piece back when your uploaded
test piece that included me caused your
channel to get struck Matt wrote about
it am I right yeah so there's a substack
article his sub stack is excellent and
uh that article is pretty eye-opening it
you know tells you you're getting near
the target uh yeah that was the that was
the first time I had heard of like the
group thing you know deleting before
publishing since then I saw one of your
friends Benjamin Boyce same thing
happened to him apparently I'm sure it's
happened to many people
so
yeah it does tell you something
I keep cutting you off as you try to
wrap it up I'm sorry no no no no not at
all not at all that's uh that's a a
useful piece of information I had
forgotten that Benjamin had had that
phenomenon but yes something is paying
attention to the inert stuff on your
channel it's not just the stuff that you
uh you publish
all right well Matt uh it's been a
pleasure and
um what is your latest video
next what next one coming up well I did
one on covid kids that's the last one I
put up on the fear mongering about how
dangerous Cove it is to Children
um one of my favorite Clips is uh some
guy on CNN saying the hospitals are
filled with with people dying and sick
of covert and then Jim Acosta Cuts in
children too
as if you know children aren't people
James
it's like uh but just had to put in like
oh children it's affecting children
children children children yeah no that
was in the morning memo and then
Hamilton 68 is the one I'm you know kind
of obsessing over now because it's such
a big story and I want to do it right
and it's also a little more complicated
um because there's you know bunch of
layers to it
you remember did you hear about that I
did you want to give a brief synopsis
sure well you had this
program under the German Marshall fund
which claimed to be tracking
Russian bots so you had this website
called The Hamilton 68 dashboard and you
saw all these bar graphs showing you
allegedly what the Russian Bots were
promoting on Twitter
well there were no Russian Bots who were
they tracking they were tracking regular
Americans and so it made this it created
this um
system
where the media could immediately
dismiss anything being uh promoted and
popularized by dissenting voices
American voices and just dismiss it as a
Russian propaganda and that's what
happened for years it's crazy until it
was discovered to be a fraud in the
Twitter files
somehow I think all of those years of
the Cold War caused there to be this
circuit inside Americans of a certain
age that means that we just you know
want to dive under the desk anytime
anybody mentions the Russians and it's
just become an excuse for everything
so when that video come out
God as soon as I can finish it oh next
next week awesome man it will be
announced presumably on your Twitter
yeah I'll upload it everywhere all right
and hopefully good enough for taibi to
write uh a bit on it cool all right well
I'm excited for that really enjoyed this
conversation
and uh I will try again it is Matt
orphola
you got it I got it yeah am I the first
one ever
and gets it no one gets it okay first
but you know you say it enough you'll
eventually get it and
but I hey that's why I go by ORF every
once they could just call me or well or
if it's been great and uh I uh look
forward to Hamilton 68.
awesome thank you Brett it's been a real
pleasure for me to you know it gets
lonely just looking at my video editing
bars and you know in the editing program
so I actually get to speak with somebody
such a great conversationalist as
yourself you know real pleasure all
right awesome
um thanks for watching everybody and we
will see you next time